et notre invité politique ce matin cet
amidon charles un bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nominés de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique et vous avez également été le
conseil régional et on va en parler
évidemment on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour tristesse havre n'ont
en rien de bon jour
zhu groupe ebra les journaux régionaux
de l'est de la france
on commence par la crise sanitaire
amélie de montchanin et c'est
l'inquiétude inquiétudes autour de la
progression du baril en delta mais aussi
inquiétudes dont le gouvernement sur la
vaccination qui marque le pas jean
castex a écrit hier aux présidents
d'associations des lieux aux présidents
de groupes parlementaires pour les
consulter sur de nouvelles mesures
on sent que le ton a changé de la part
du gouvernement est ce que clairement le
gouvernement envisage de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire alors ce qui est
certain c'est qu'effectivement nous
avons une ouverture progressive de
descons finaux et qui est précieuse qui
était attendu et qui se fait dans un
pays où les indicateurs sanitaires nous
permettent de poursuivre ce
déconfinement ça c'est la première chose
qu'il faut dire aux français la deuxième
chose que c'est que effectivement le
variant les variants et on le sait
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois restent
évidemment un danger est notre meilleure
arme contre le variant aussi contre
l'épidémie en général c'est la
vaccination c'est que pendant deux mois
des mois et des mois de manière légitime
les organisations syndicales les agents
publics m'ont demandé à ce que nous
protégions bien les agents publics et
c'était une demande légitime et nous
avons fait nos meilleurs efforts en
termes d'organisation du travail du
télétravail des masques l'ensemble des
mesures graves ont pris pour bien
ralentir l'épidémie
aujourd'hui on a une difficulté
notamment dans les lieux de soins mag
l'hôpital les ehpad
on ne peut pas accepter que quand vous
veniez vous faire soigner quand vous
êtes résidents en ehpad
le virus circule autour de vous quitte à
vous infecter parce que les soignants ne
sont pas assez vacciner aujourd'hui on a
un peu moins de la moitié seulement des
soignants des pâtes qui sont vaccinées
donc on est en train de prendre des
mesures très fort d'accompagnement de
facilitation d'explication on regarde
les chiffres tous les jours et
effectivement en libérant la dyle promis
cela dit si nous voyons que nous sommes
en risque de rentrer dans l'automne avec
un seuil vaccinale trop faible
alors nous devrons rendre la vaccination
est temps pour les soignants parce que
les lieux de soins sont des lieux où
vous ne pouvez pas prendre le risque
d'attraper que ça veut dire ça veut dire
mais dimanche un qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité d confinement total sans un
processus de vaccination
déjà c'est parce qu on se vaccine qu'on
arrive à faire à l'ancienne avec une
amie ça se voit dans tous les pays y a
pas de plan b
y a pas de plan b le dit aux français
vaccinés vous sinon le déconfinement
échoit en tout cas le risque d'échec est
important ce risque des variants les
scientifiques nous ont bien expliqué
c'est un risque dans toute épidémie
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes vacciné même
si vous êtes contaminé par un nouveau
variant ce que nous voyons c'est que
vous n'allez pas à l'hôpital et c'est
que vous n'y a pas de forme grave donc
en fait comme beaucoup d'autres maladies
c'est une maladie mais elle ne vous
emmène pas aurait amené à sion et
surtout après avec un risque quand même
il faut le dire très fort de décéder ce
sont des questions de vie ou de mort on
n'est pas propre à prendre ces sujets à
la légère donc ce que nous disons mais
ils m'ont en tant que mise la fonction
publique par ailleurs évidemment premise
avait vu consulte largement ce qui
montre aussi le respect que nous avons
des élus des associations d'élus des
parlementaires moi en tant que mise à
fond sur public mon rôle c'est de
faciliter au maximum la vaccination
bien sûr de l'ensemble de la population
des agents publics
donc on va installer voyez des lieux
vaccination en bas des cités
administratives
on va faciliter est ce que c'est la
facilité au maximum ou est ce que c'est
la rendre obligatoire est ce que pour
les personnels de la fonction publique
qui sont au contact avec du public il
faut rendre cette vaccination
obligatoire est par exemple avec pour
les enseignants il faut rendre cette
vaccination clairement il ya une
distinction à faire les lieux de santé
doivent être des lieux extrêmement
protégé et donc les soignants c'est un
enjeu très particulier que nous
regardons comment un jeu très
particulier pour le reste des français
on le voit d'ailleurs le désir vaccinale
est quand même important maintenant il
ya parfois des enjeux pratiques parfois
le sandjak signalé loin parfois il c'est
votre rendez vous sur vos horaires de
travail ou comment on vous assure vous
n'avez pas perdre de salaire
comment si vous vacciner vos enfants on
vous donne aussi des facilités horaire
donc on est en train d'organiser les
choses très concrètement très localement
très avec beaucoup de volontarisme
parce que nous on est plusieurs
d'où l'on taille dans sa lettre il n'est
pas seulement sur le voile sur le
volontariat jean castex alors il parle
de l'obligation pour les soignants ça ça
a l'air assez acté un du côté du
gouvernement
mais il demande aussi aux élus locaux et
aux parlementaires de faire des
propositions de donner leur avis sur un
élargissement de la vaccination
obligatoire
jusqu'où il faut l'élargir pour vous si
on demande des propositions c'est pas
pour juger ne vous répond ce matin avec
les conclusions
première chose on savait dire que vous y
réfléchissez clairement à l'ouvrir à
orly trois autres catégories question
les tests vous avez vu qu'on réfléchit
aussi à dire à mon données est-ce qu'on
veut mettre de l'argent public dans des
tests à répétition si on peut se faire
vacciner ce qui évite d'ailleurs de
devoir revenir très souvent dans les
lieux de soins dans les pharmacies dans
les laboratoires donc il ya beaucoup de
choses soit à moi mon nom je savais bien
fini la gratuité des tests ni on a fait
le reste de confort mais mini's la
fonction publique
j'ai la responsabilité de cinq millions
d'agents certains d'entre eux sont des
soignants pour eux pour leur santé c'est
une obligation professionnelle
vous venez soigner des gens le but n'est
pas que vous leur transmettiez une
maladie mais a dit que potentiellement
le cep est grave pour les soignants il
ya évidemment des réflexions très
poussée très avancées pour le reste des
français comme pour le reste des agents
publics
notre enjeu c'est qu' aucun frein
matériel organisationnel logistique ne
vienne perturber une campagne vaccinale
que nous devons poursuivre tous les
scientifiques le disent nous serons plus
forts face il ya un critère mais tout le
monde y accéder est ce que vous dites si
à telle date tant de sûreté nationale
des agents publics ne sont pas vaccinés
il y aura une vaccination est gagnant
audio autre que les soignants sur les
soignants les verra défier le seuil haut
80% minimum de soignants se vacciner si
on n'y arrive pas par la volonté
individuelle et bien il faudrait qu'on
prenne des points 80 % d'ailleurs parce
qu'on compare et on y aurait évidemment
c'est plus on est près 100 % lui sert
donc il faut au moins 80% si on n'est
pas 80% on le rendra
et c'était déjà on sait beaucoup plus
obligatoire à nouveau notre notre ange
et pourquoi on fait tout ça parce que la
continuité de la vie démocratique
éducatives culturelles économiques
personnels
on a quand même moi je le vois bien des
agents publics qui parfois depuis plus
d'un an on télétravail est parce qu on a
d'ailleurs mis des moyens nouveaux et
c'est très bien
mais on a quand même besoin vous voyez
de retrouver collective sera hier encore
je serai avec les syndicats sur un
accord pour le télétravail télétravail
ça a changé la vie
effectivement d'une administration qui
jusque là voyez ça comme quelque chose
de très anecdotique ou très parcellaires
ça a eu des conséquences positives que
les gens veulent garder et c'est normal
et moi je l'accompagné ç'a eu aussi des
enjeux de difficultés l'égalité homme
femme de fer lui les équipes donc il est
accompagné de quelle manière juste à
main longchamp est ce qu'il ya un
encadrement tss télétravail pour la
fonction publique tout à fait donc on
est en train de travailler a écrit un
accord cadre qui sera soumis au vote des
aurès syndicales et des employeurs le 13
juillet cet accord il va bien au delà de
la question de savoir si on télétravail
un deux ou trois jours
comme c'était le cas avant il regarde le
droit à la déconnexion il regarde ce
qu'on peut faire aussi pour accompagner
par exemple les personnes qui ont les
femmes enceintes les personnes qui sont
des projets qui aident et proches
aidants comme on dit qui est notamment
des personnes fragiles en faire aussi un
aimant de souplesse mais aussi un
élément comment on pense le dialogue
social comme on organise aussi la vie
d'une équipe qui est à la fois pour
certains bureaux pour certains en
télétravail et si le gaz et les
indemnités est ce qui aura un effet
avant les agents de la fonction publique
en compensation financière donc c'est
une proposition que j'ai faite hier pour
que dans l'année si vous télétravail et
deux jours par semaine vous ayez 220
euros de compensation sur les frais que
ça peut engendrer
on est sur un accord très ambitieux très
très novateur très moderne
peut-être même d'ailleurs plus ambitieux
que ce qui a été fait dans un secteur
privé sûr c'est un travail que nous
avons mené et traître est à la fois
rapidement mais très en profondeur parce
que cet organe est sans nouvelles du
travail c'est quelque chose qu'on doit
aussi garder mais en regardant ce que la
crise nous a appris en conséquence
positive à valoriser et puis en chose
qu'il faut qu'on organise mieux et
notamment le but c'est bien sûr que
personne ne fasse 5 jours de télétravail
sur les gens sur simple parce que 5
millions d'agents dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure quand bien sont concernés par
le télétravail alors nous parlons alors
cet accord cadre il a vocation à
concerner l'ensemble des versants et
aujourd'hui à un traitement aujourd'hui
alors j'agis pas les chiffres
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mais avant que
nous baissions le quota de jours puisque
nous sommes passés de 5 jours sur 5 puis
à 23 jours puis maintenant aujourd'hui
ces deux jours par semaine
il ya quelques semaines 80% j'adore des
agents des administrations centrales
et est en télétravail 50% de ceux qui
sont dans l'état des préfectures et sous
préfectures
c'est une révolution évidemment je tiens
à le dire
le but n'est pas qu'on reste cinq jours
sur cinq ans de travail parce qu'on voit
bien que pour l'animation du travail
pour le collectif de travail évidemment
besoin de retrouver ses collègues
mais le but n'est pas non plus qu'on
repasse ensemble ils ont présidentielle
c'est pas que tout cet effort là
d'accélération aussi de nouvelles
confiance aussi d'un travail qui était
organique et organiser tout ça soit mis
derrière nous on va parler d'un autre
sujet apparaît de la réforme des
retraites pas de tabou dit zhu à propos
de la réforme des retraites c'est ce que
dit le gouvernement gabriela talent dit
qu'il y aura une réforme des retraites
la question est de savoir quand alors
quand et quelle réforme des retraites
surtout moi je vais pas vous parler ce
matin de calendrier parce que savoir si
c'est maintenant six mois dans un an je
pense que ce qui compte surtout c'est de
dire aux français le choix c'est pas une
question d'opportunisme politique c'est
pas de savoir quand il a skié la bonne
fenêtre pour annoncer telle ou telle
mesure c'est de rendre sa cohérent avec
notre première priorité qu'est la
relance économique la relance de notre
pays
comment fait de cette réforme aussi un
outil au service de la relance c'est une
réforme des retraites c'est fait pour
qui c'est fait pour les actifs c'est
fait pour que ceux qui travaillent
puissent continuer et bien à profiter
j'allais dire leur travail tout en
finançant un système kiwi d'un système
de solidarité intergénérationnelle
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays on a
quand même des grands défis qui sont
autour de cette réforme on a le défi du
taux d'emploi des jeunes et le taux de
chômage des jeunes
on a le défi du taux d'emploi du taux
chômage des seniors on a beaucoup de
questions sur la capacité vous voyez à
articuler cette réforme
avec le retour de la prospérité le
retour la croissance leur tour la
création d'emplois et donc c'est par
cohérence c'est par choix économiques
nous devrons décider et c'est un choix
que nous prîmes justes on est sûr
qu'elle réforme amélie dimanche un parce
qu'on a l'impression que là on n'entend
plus du tout parler de la réforme qui
était prévu à la base c'est à dire la
réforme par point pour simplifier un peu
les choses
là on est plus que sur une réforme
paramétrique d'allongement
un vitrage des départs savez ils seront
rendus par le président le premier
ministre et ils seront précis il ya
plein d'anjou au toit la forme des
retraites est un enjeu d'équité
pourquoi et des différences aussi grande
entre des hommes et des femmes qui font
des métiers mais qui juste non par dream
est le même statut vous avez un enjeu
ensuite d'efficacité économique
comment cette réforme peut aussi aussi
être accompagné du fait que les
personnes qui ont plus de 50 ans et plus
de possibilités pour rester dans
l'emploi
comment les jeunes travaillent plus ça
vous fait plus de cotisants s'il ya le
taux de chômage des seniors est toujours
jeune belle ça vous fait plus de
cotisants il ya l'enjeu ensuite de large
et est ce que la réforme systémique elle
est encore sur la table ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on en est à s'occuper à
l' équilibre du régime et a donc à
s'occuper de l'âge de départ de toute
façon c'est une réforme systémique je
prends la fonction publique je regarde
dans mon périmètre d'action il ya
évidemment une réforme systémique
6 quelle que soit la réforme des
retraites cor que l'on imagine faire
pourquoi aujourd'hui un agent public
fonctionnaires qui à la fin du mois
rassure son bulletin de paye une somme
d'argent qui est versée vous savez que
parfois il y a que la moitié de ce qui
lui est versée qu'ils cotisent retraites
cette absurde ça ne peut pas tenir vous
voyez bien qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets
qui est la réforme des retraites en elle
même mais pour qu'elle réussisse dans un
contexte où notre priorité absolue c'est
la relance et c'est aussi évidemment de
l'efficacité c'est l'équité qui a
énormément sujet à ouvrir en parallèle
et donc c'est tous ses arbitrages
va-t-il doivent être réellement c'était
opportun de l'ouvrir rouvrir ce dossier
à quelques mois de la présidentielle
mais vous savez à nouveau c'est pas de
l'opportunisme politique que c'est un
très vieux sujet c est aussi du courage
de dire aux français que les sujets sur
lesquels nous étions engagés nous avions
agi ils n'ont pas disparu les défis qui
était posée à l'époque n'ont pas disparu
simplement qu'il se pose aujourd'hui
dans un contexte qui a changé donc ça va
être intéressant j'ai eu deux campagnes
mais c'est la solidarité entre les
générations
le modèle social français ce les enjeux
dont je viens de vous parler aussi
d'efficacité quand vous voyez que une
partie seulement de ce que toucher les
fonctionnaires cotisent à la retraite et
on voit bien qu'il ya des enjeux massif
majeur de réforme donc d'abord oui comme
je disais n'y a pas de tabou on ya
travaillé et beaucoup en 2019
le contexte aujourd'hui issus de la
relance évidemment ça
c'est un sujet le sujet n'a pas été
réglée par la crise au contraire comme
on doit travailler sur le sujet c'est
bien les arbitrages qui aurait pris une
approche autre sujet d'actualité favre
est oui cette perquisition hier place
vendôme dans les bureaux de votre
collègue lise la justice eric dupond
moretti qui est soupçonnée par la
justice de conflit entre sa fonction de
ministre et sa fonction d'avocat est-ce
que c'est nabeul pour le garde des
sceaux savez j'ai un principe tissus et
de respecter les institutions et quand
vous êtes ministre au gouvernement
eh bien j'ai un principe que j'applique
strictement c'est que je ne commande pas
ni des décisions de justice ni des
enquêtes de justice et donc je n'aurai
sur ce sujet aucun commentaire à faire
les dimensions politiques néanmoins il
ya une dimension politique et mais voyez
si on commence à mêler politique et
discussions sur la justice alors
l'indépendance de la justice n'est plus
garantie et donc je suis plus dans mon
rôle donc je ne ferai aucun commentaire
les agents de la fonction publique sont
mobilisés ils sont mobilisés il ya
quelques jours pour demander une
augmentation de leur rémunération
voulait rencontrer ces agents de la
fonction publique
vous allez leur accorder cette
augmentation tous les ans il ya un
moment un peu solennel ont fait à la
fois le bilan et on dire les
perspectives ce rendez vous a lieu mardi
prochain ce sera un moment important
parce qu'on va regarder effectivement
tout ce qu'on a fait depuis 2007
et vous savez qu'on a les enseignants
sur les chercheurs sur les forces de
l'ordre sur les soignants fait beaucoup
de choses qui ont augmenté le pouvoir
d'achat on va aussi tracer des
perspectives à nouveau on vient de
parler de la relance on vient de parler
du contexte économique de notre pays a
parlé de ce que nous avons à faire
devant nous pour ces 5 millions d'hommes
et de femmes
et puis on va regarder mais aussi des
enjeux concrets qui ne sont pas toujours
des enjeux salariaux mais oui enfin
pouvoir d'achat moi j'ai toujours
travaillé en étant très clair avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
ma priorité c'est de résoudre les
inégalités y avait une illégalité qui
était criante qui était à mon avis
d'ailleurs très dangereuse c'est que les
fonctionnaires les agents publics paient
jusqu'à maintenant eux mêmes pour la
plupart d'entre 100 % de leur mutuelle
santé donc ça crée une inégalité très
forte par rapport à l'accès à la santé
on sort d'une crise sanitaire c'était
absurde que nous laissions perdure un
système où cinq millions de français
étaient dans une situation où le coût
d'accès à la santé le coût de la
mutuelle la complémentaire santé étaient
plus grands à partir du 1er janvier 2022
et ça a été discuté et acter cette
semaine
syndicale tous les agents publics de
l'état auront 15 euros par mois par
agent pour faciliter payer contribuer à
la promotion de la santé c'est un
élément qui n'est pas un élément de
salaire c'est un dément le pouvoir
d'achat et donc moi je suis très
pragmatique je ferai des annonces mardi
et comme c'est mardi ben je les ferai
mardi juste un mot alors vous il ya des
choses qui ont déjà été actée mais
est-ce que sur leur salaire est ce qu'il
y aura
vous envisagez un dégel du point dadis
qui sert de calcul de base les achats à
mardi je vous dis que moi mon enjeu
prioritaire c'est de s'occuper des
inégalités entre les hommes et les
femmes c'est de regarder ce qu'on fait
pour les ceux qui ont les plus petits
salaires
c'est de s'occuper de choses parfois qui
sont dans les discussions depuis dix ou
quinze ans sa méthode complémentaire
santé
ça fait dix ou kessas avec thé mais sur
le dégel est-ce que vous l'envisagez ou
est ce que vous dites c'est non il n'y
aura pas de dégel que si je faisais des
rendez vous le mardi c'est pas pour vous
en faire les annonces le vendredi on va
parler de la réforme de la haute
fonction publique et à fabrice oui parce
que vous avez lancée et à une
consultation suis au mois de mai sur ça
c'est bien lancé sur la réforme de la
haute fonction publique avec quand même
cette date nous aviez donné au 1er
janvier vous vous espérez pouvoir faire
passer quoi
d'ici au 1er janvier en matière de
réforme de la haute fonction on a
effectivement consulter les 12000 hauts
fonctionnaires concernés par la réforme
7000 d'entre eux ont fait part de leurs
attentes leurs difficultés de ce qui
fonctionne bien de ce qui fonctionne
moins bien ouais je rendrai public les
résultats de cette consultation autour
d'une nouvelle réunion que le premier
ministre et moi-même tiendront la
semaine prochaine le 8 juillet au soleil
la semaine prochain exactement c'est une
semaine vous voyez on avance sur
beaucoup de sujets et le but c'est que
nous puissions au vu cette consultation
définir clairement concrètement matin la
mise en oeuvre au 1er janvier 2022 vous
aurez l'institut national du service
public qui viendra en place et lieu de
l'ena aussi repenser non seulement la
formation initiale aussi la formation
continue créé une culture commune pour
tous nos fonctionnaires vous aurez la
création de notre drh des talents des
directions interministérielles à
l'encadrement super de l'état vous aurez
la création d'un corps des ennemis
savate de l'état et donc au 1er janvier
ce que le président a annoncé le 8 avril
sera créé rendu au fond il reste
l'association dont vous parlez vous en
avez vous les retours voulait rendrez
public
est ce que c'est de nature à changer la
réforme est-ce que du coup l'action
firme et vous dites il ya des choses
qu'on va changer dans la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme c'est d'abord de nature à
confirmer que s'occuper du recrutement
de la formation de la gestion des
carrières est essentiel que les 7000
personnes que consultant disent tout
on a besoin d'eux au fond avoir des
carrières qu'ils soient mieux
accompagnés qui dépend moins du hasard
ou du déterminisme du classement - des
corporatismes et ça ressort très
massivement ensuite évidemment cette
consultation a été fait parce que
maintenant on rentre dans un sujet
ministère par ministère métier par
métier et donc il faut que ça fonctionne
pour tout le monde et donc entre les
principes de l'ordonnancé qui était
publié au journal officiel le 3 juin
et maintenant la mise en oeuvre d'ici au
1er janvier c'est essentiel de faire les
choses de manière pragmatique et concret
dans les tailles au regard de l'histoire
française
est ce que vous considérez qu'en si peu
de temps la haute fonction publique
française est réformable réellement très
fort je suis d'abord absolument
convaincue qu'elle a besoin de se
transformer je suis absolument convaincu
que les agents et les hauts
fonctionnaires et cadres de l'état
attendent des changements et je suis
absolument convaincu que la sortie de
crise le fait que nous rentrions dans un
nouveau siècle qui est des nouveaux
enjeux écologiques numérique
technologiques les enjeux de la baisse
des valeurs de la république fait que 1
évidemment il faut faire cette réforme
et je peux vous dire que les agents et
les hauts fonctionnaires l'attendent
avec 84%
les agents publics soutiennent la
réforme parce qu'il voit bien que la
manière dont fonctionne hors encadrement
doit être mise à jour doit rester
attractif aussi ce que notre combat
c'est que les jeunes puissent venir
travailler aussi s'engager au service de
l'intérêt général
allez on va parler des régionales
maintenant me line beauchamp parce que
vous avez été élu dimanche conseiller
régional dit
de france la séance d'installation du
nouveau conseil régional a lieu ce matin
vous irez siéger au conseil régional
vous à plein temps c'est un peu on sent
que ça cesse a fait quelques donc j'ai
été élu effectivement donc maintenant
dimanche dernier ça fait quelques jours
que tout le monde me pose cette question
je peux vous dire sincèrement être qui à
l'exemple d'agnès besoin par exemple
mais je peux vous dire sincèrement moi
ma conception de la politique c'est que
quand ce territoire qui m'a élu député
en 2010 est que je n'ai jamais cessé de
servir dans l'ensemble des fonctions m
l'essonne au fond sur la table du
conseil et mini c'est à dire porter ces
sujets au plus haut niveau de l'état
pour que les projets du territoire les
projets des élus et projets des citoyens
avance donc évidemment pour moi la
conception de la politique que j'ai
c'est que quand vous confier un mandat
c'est un honneur de servir d'y aller à
fond de jouer son rôle évidemment on va
pas être majoritaire au conseil régional
mais quelles sont vos ambitions mais je
veux nationale mais votre score
on prend un second tour ce sont les
mêmes ambitions que celles qu'on a
envoyé au parlement européen vous avez
un groupe renaissance qui n'est pas
majoritaire mais qui fait avancer les
sujets qui tient un discours de vérité
tient un discours d'ambition moi je peux
vous dire on serait dans une opposition
constructive et que quand madame
pécresse proposant les choses utiles à
la région eh bien nous serons à ses
côtés
mais quand on tombera dans soit du
clientélisme partisans soit dans un
espèce de lutte absolument stérile qui
consiste à dire que le programme des
régions de ces de faire la guerre à
l'état
eh bien nous combattrons ça parce que
état et région sont partenaires tu vois
un scoop
vous avez été aux iphone et bien nous
devons travailler ensemble la relance
économique en est un bon exemple
les enjeux effectivement de notre
territoire doivent être portés de
manière conjointe entre une politique
nationale et évidemment les compétences
de la région sur sur la sécurité par
exemple quand a dit ce matin dans le
parisien qu'elle va lancer très
rapidement le doublement des brigades
régionales de sécurité ça vous
soutiendrez vous regardez à quoi ça sert
regardons comment s'est organisée
regardons si c'est si c'est fait en
coordination avec de l'ambition avec du
concret on aurait tort de dire de dire
non si c'est fait pour expliquer que
comme ce qu'on avait entendu grâce aux
régions on a eu des masques mais
arrêtons ça
l'hélico les régions et compétences dans
les lycées c'est très bien qu'elle
fournisse des masses dans les lycées
puis l'état des compétents des hôpitaux
mais c'est très bien que l'état fournit
zemma dans les hôpitaux
donc c'est aussi pour qu on puisse avoir
un discours de vérité et puis c'est pour
faire autre chose c'est parce que moi la
politique voyez je crois
fondée mans qu'elle doit parler aux
français et la france quand je vois à
droite ou à gauche aujourd'hui lundi
tribune des 200 pour hidalgo la tribune
et 92 pour les là c'est ce qui m'a fait
moi je peux vous dire quitter la droite
en 2016 on a l'impression qu'on est
retourné dans un monde où les politiques
par la mm et parlent d'eux mêmes parlent
pas ni aux français ni à la france est
donc s'engager en politique pour moi
c'est pas de revivre le match 2016 que
les français d'ailleurs 2007 ont voulu
envoyer éjecté de dire on en a marre
d'un système où les politiciens se
parlent d'eux-mêmes et eux mêmes plutôt
qu'en français des français le président
la république contrairement à xavier
bertrand aux autres il a un projet pour
la france
il a pas un projet qui change tous les
matins de caractère relatif à cela dit
un peu plus si je vais les sondages au
fond et l'opportunisme l'outrance va me
permettre de me poser ce que les
français ils ont parlé au président de
la république qui ne sont pas là la
majorité dimanche où ils se sont
largement abstenues parce qu'il
considère qu'il ya une rupture et qu'ils
ne se sentent pas écoutés vos candidats
de la majorité présidentielle ils sont
arrivés derniers dans quasiment toutes
les régions au second tour et le
président de la république dit moi je ne
tire pas de conséquences nationales de
cette élection c'est une élection locale
est-ce que vous avez l'impression vous
l'entendez vous le message des français
ce que j'ai entendu c'est que les
présidents sortants ont été réélus par
tout ça veut dire qu'ils avaient pas de
passes à une alternative quelle qu'elle
soit et pas de raison qu'on basculer
d'un côté ou un autre bon et donc nous
on avait une nouvelle alternative à
proposer ça pas plus intéressé que les
alternatives existantes tant l'envié vue
on a aussi eu qui a rassuré d'abstention
qu'est ce qui nourrit l'abstention c'est
le petit jeu politicien que les français
ont voulu dégager du zen manière en 2017
ou les partis politiques parlent d'eux
mêmes ou les sénateurs écrivent des
lettres pour expliquer qu'il faut
s'intéresser aussi à ne départage
où sont les projets où sont les
programmes ou et le cap
pourquoi emmanuel macron au fond mais il
ya des gens qui me disaient c'est
étrange il a une bonne popularité parce
que depuis 2010 est à quoi on s'est
attachée à fixer un cap à être clair ça
nous donne la solidité et ça intéresse
les français de voir que nous sommes
constants ensuite il y aura des choix
ils diront est ce qu'on continue ou
est-ce qu'on change mais vous voyez ce
que l'on a vu c'est que le désintérêt
pour la politique
il est pour moi moi j'ai quitté vous
savez en 2016
juste après la primaire la droite j'ai
quitté parce que c'était une guerre
fratricide
c'est un moment où les projets je peux
vous le dire ont été faits pas pour les
français ils ont été faites par rapport
aux autres il fallait se mettre plus à
droite
il fallait sur celle qu'on pousse à
gauche il fallait se recentrer
c'est dur relatif c'est du relativisme
les français n'en veulent plus et je
pense que quand vous voyez 200 élus qui
appelle à quelque chose 92 à autre chose
et qu'on a toujours pas compris quel
était le projet cette politique n'a elle
détourne les français vont leur palier
brune et à droite
vous avez été proche de valérie pécresse
il est probable qu'elle soit dans la
course à la présidentielle vous en
pensez penseriez quoi je vous le redis
si nous sommes capables en france
d'avoir un débat politique qui parle du
projet qui parle de la france et qui
parle des français alors ce sera un
débat politique qui peut être
intéressera les français à la politique
si c'est pour savoir si on est plus au
sens plus progressistes plus à droite
plus dur sur s'ils pouvaient se madame
pécresse en particulier est introduit
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose je n'ai
pas compris je n'ai l'impression qu'on
est en train de se parler des
calendriers des des positionnements je
suis plus comme si je suis plus comme ça
au fond à nouveau les hommes politiques
qui parlent d'eux mêmes plutôt que de
parler de la france qui se parlent entre
eux plutôt de parler aux français
je pense que ça se désintéresse les
français l'apprécient et je veux vous
dire que moi j y ai tourné le dos et
j'en suis bien content parce que un
engagement au service de son pays
ça ne peut pas être un engagement au
service de son parti et moi je vois là
oui je vais pas vous parler du futur la
république en marche pas parce que je
sais tu pas un sujet mais un mois
peut-être sur le futur dans les pélicans
marche parce qu'au vu des résultats
électoraux quel est le futur de la
république en marche et sociale niesr
erin et il peut encore porter ce
mouvement et le futur la république est
en marche c'est quoi c'est d'être un
outil au service d'un projet politique
et donc il n'y a pas que c'est pas
d'être un mouvement services d' emmanuel
macron surtout quand on voit le résultat
des élections intermédiaires
c'est d'être au service d'un projet
c'est pour ça que je me suis engagé
parce que c'était pour la première fois
depuis bien longtemps qu'on a mis le
pays
les français aujourd'hui la relance
typiquement la relance où sont les 100 %
des hommes et femmes politiques de
droite ou de gauche
quelle que soit leur étiquette qui
disent aujourd'hui ce qu'on doit faire
réussir c'est la relance on met derrière
nous nos étiquettes on met la haine au
combat partisan et oui on s'engage
on s'engage à et état et on s'engage
avec mon mandat une qu'on soit dans
l'opposition où qu'on soit dans la
majorité
tu es le fait majoritaire dans les
régions c'est quoi c'est de dire il ya
la majorité qui décide tout seul c'est
l'opposition qui est toujours contre et
puis tout cas pas récente et les clubs
du milieu ça ça décédé les terres
sacrées de l'abstention et ce sera loin
de la fin merci beaucoup merci mon
challenge d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin on regarde la une du dauphiné
fabriquer le vaccin le vaccin peut être
bientôt obligatoire c'est à la une des
journaux du groupe ebra
merci
[Musique]